Let's get back to the point. Black Adam,
you big opening.
Huge. By the way, the thing that's
crazy about it being so f***ing big,
your fan base is engaged, everybody's
engaged. You make an announcement and
your announcement is talking about,
hey, we're not going to continue the
world of Black Adam, right?
For me, I'm curious.
I want to know why, especially when
there's such a successful opening.
You seem to have the appetite from your
fan base for more.
What's the reason or the reasons for
the stopping of Black Adam?
I think that Black Adam got caught in a
vortex of.
New leadership.
And at that time, as we were creating
Black Adam, developing it, shooting
black Adam, we got knocked down a
little bit because of Covid and the
shutdowns got back up.
There were so many changes in
leadership. And as you know, any time
you have a company, but especially that
size and magnitude, that's a publicly
traded company and you have all those
changes in leadership, you have people
coming in who creatively, fiscally are
going to make decisions that you may
not agree with philosophically.
So I think Black Adam was one of those
movies that got caught in that web of
new leadership.
And, you know, that will always be one
of the. One of the biggest mysteries, I
think, not only for me and us on our
end, but also throughout our business,
because that's a Kevin question.
But that that was a question out of
Wall Street. That was a question out of
Hollywood. That was a question like,
wait a second. You had the biggest
opening of your career.
Sure. No China that could have been
maybe 100, maybe 200 more million
dollars. You're establishing a new
superhero. You want to grow out the
franchise. You bring back Superman and
Henry Cavill. The world went crazy.
And also, too.
And you and I, you were texting me this
on opening weekend is we created a
diverse superhero portfolio where we
had just men and women of color, you
know, in black Adam, too, as well.
So I think I was more I was impressed by
the execution. Yeah, I know our black
Adam, how close the movie was the
project. And that was one that was near
and dear to your heart and cracking the
code. It seemed that cracking the code
on the world of superhero is something,
of course, that you are very ambitious
about doing. And what I thought you
did, I was like, Oh, that's dope as
f***. He put his mind to it and he did
it like, the s***'s happening.
They're in production, they're shooting
the movie. F***, it's done.
Damn, Release the trailer. S*** look
good. Dj Congrats.
F***. All right, you then release the
movie. Movie has success behind it.
You get some positive dollars in the
goddamn box office behind it.
In a time where the box office seemed
to be taking hits dips.
So I don't know.
It was just it was a weird thing for me
and just not knowing.
But to hear you say that it makes
sense, you know, when there's a
changing of the guard, sometimes the
business changes as well, and
rightfully so, right? Like we can't be
a part of the world of why on that
side. But and giving them the best
opportunity to make more and do more.
That's our job. That's what we come in.
Exactly.
And you know, I think as business minded
people, who are you and I who are
always thinking audience first.
Yes. We look at and respect the bottom
line economically, but also when you
think about opportunity and creating
opportunity and creating things that
are fresh and delivering for the
audience, which is our number one boss.
When when that wasn't looked at through
that lens, it makes things a little bit
more challenging, I think, for guys
like you and I where you go, are you
sure you want to do this? But hey, at
the end of the day, you know what it
is? It's like new ownership coming in,
buying an NFL team and going, all
right, not my head coach, not my
quarterback. Doesn't matter how many
times you won a Super Bowl, doesn't
matter how many rings we got, I'm going
with somebody else. Great example.
Yeah, that's a great example.